i think it was good for a lot of people
to go and reconnect
yes with family right and
maybe they needed to reconnect with
um who who they were
before they moved to places like new
york
or their original psychiatrist yes yeah
or the original yeah
absolutely it knows how to help right
exactly like
you were long overdue for these
anti-depressants yeah
it's it's [ __ ] it's
wild to think about who we all were
like before we knew
that this could happen right and then
now having this [ __ ] think about
death in a real way yeah absolutely
in an actual real way like like yeah
this ends and we don't know when
right could be sooner than not like you
know
i remember like you know like
comorbidities
when that start you know which is you
know you know fat
you know i just remember like when they
started talking about comorbidities
right morbidities i was like you know i
just get nervous i'm like what is
what are these comorbidities and and and
i don't have diabetes or anything like
that but they're like that's a big one
i'm like yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a big there's a comic
on the bigger side
who was he he died yeah from covet this
guy kenny ortega
big guy funny dude funny guy could kill
in pretty much any room
and unfortunately passed away got
covered passed away and that's the thing
like you start thinking about him like
[ __ ] i'm like all right i don't have
diabetes right i'm like but i
[ __ ] smoke i don't i'm not smoking
now but i'm like and then you have the
weight
right and then i'm 36. right i'm like
i'm not and they're like you know i'd
always look at that chart
mm-hmm we're like well when the brackets
of your head the brackets i'm like
well people in their 30s but i'm like
i'm 36.
yeah and it it's you know and and i was
an alcoholic
and a drug addict right for a decade
over a day well over decades yeah
from 13 to 25 about 12 years
and you go you go yeah i don't know that
i want to go to the dance
no with this stay home yeah yeah and a
lot of
people went home they went back to their
family and i don't judge them for
it go for it right do that and also it's
your family you don't even know if
they're gonna live
right you don't know if your parents are
gonna live yeah so you're gonna sit
there and
what tough it out in new york city right
that's
insane behavior i know a lot of people
that went
back home to me for me there's no home
to go that's
and there hasn't been a home to go
forever right right yeah and
um i guess i could have went home right
but i mean i live with my girlfriend
right no yeah you have a life yeah i
have a certain age
yeah yeah where it's harder to do that
right and it's harder to do that
my father and his wife would have been
like please
die alone like they would have been like
please like die
like have a decency right after all the
[ __ ] you've talked about
us after all the the money you've made
like dragging our names through the mud
please do not come back here to die
like i mean did i want to die there like
do i want to die there with my
stepmother rolling her eyes
rolling her eyes out nobody wants to be
dying and having somebody give you a
shady look
yeah nobody wants like a dirty look like
like not so funny now or you're fat ass
and i'm just like
my last few actions would be to cough on
you
yeah i mean so there was nowhere but
then you start thinking about like i'm
like if i
die these were dark thoughts like you
have a girlfriend yeah i'm single
i mean i guess i could call one of these
guys in their early 20s and i've
you know [ __ ] because they like hotel
rooms and sneakers and going
hey would you want to sit by my bedside
while i die
it's such
i don't know i'm like hey no they'll
straight up be like am i in a will or
something
i'll have to like i'm like yeah yeah but
it's [ __ ] right
because i've been i you don't have much
i have this career
right i have the career yes that's what
i have and the career is good
but the career is the least the last
thing you want
yes if you're dying right right right
but if when there's no opportunities
it's the career is the first thing you
want so
the career is what you want it's either
first or last in a lot of places
yeah yeah it's weird to think about
because i had those thoughts you know i
had those thoughts like i was on the
roads i was on the road
during the pandemic when cases would
drop mm-hmm well they would drive like
last summer or people like it's over and
i'm like all right
you get a few shows in and then we're
like it ain't over and yeah
cases went up and then we back off the
road but like i was out on the road i
got my opener was like 24
25 and he's fine he was young
yeah and he's like his whole thing was
he's like no no one's [ __ ] anymore
and i can't go out to bars and my whole
thing in my head i'm like i'm gonna die
alone
yeah you know what i mean yeah like i'm
like well
i understand that he's like yeah the
[ __ ] bars
these chicks on tinder they're weird
because the pandemic i'm like
understood right but also i will
gonna die here alone but
but in his to his uh to what he's saying
yeah you know not being able to go out
to the bars and these restaurants
closing
yeah some of them had to go yes yes some
of these restaurants had yeah
it was i and it's just like a friend
said that like oh they can use covet as
an excuse
right to close up yes but some of them
good yeah i'm happy your dream was
crushed
some of them need to go i didn't need to
eat at your shitty burger restaurant
yeah that people showed up to it had
horrible brunch
yes and it's like people were like oh
this is no good
right board up the walls yeah i'm happy
good
yeah you know what i i hope somebody i
don't want to say death but
i just hope someone was affected because
i don't want it coming back yeah yeah no
i want
a little lung scar i don't want someone
sponsoring this place
i don't want to go fund me appearing no
i don't want to be nervous
i don't i hope you realize your life
shouldn't be dedicated to sriracha aioli
no get out of my life yeah no stuff
there are necessary changes
yeah you're jarring things yeah no
you're jarring
you annoy me